so in the early days of this disease the
first conservation management action was
to put some Devils away somewhere safe
isolated from the disease where we could
maintain a population of healthy Devils
that could be used to reintroduce them
to the wild the rate at which Tasmanian
Devils have been declining throughout
Tasmania makes the threat of extinction
a possible outcome and we're quite
concerned about that and that's why
we're trying to put our efforts and to
learn more about the disease itself at
the moment we're working with the genome
sequence and with a large drug screen
here at the Sanger Institute to try to
identify targeted molecules which act
against specific mutated proteins in the
devil cancer which may be effective
treatments for this disease we still
have a lot of work to do but we have
researchers from all over the world
working on this problem and in the UK
and in Tasmania and in in Hobart and so
we hope that eventually we will have
something that could tip the balance in
favor of the Tasmanian Devil and give
them a fighting chance to survive in the
wild